[Musique]
c'est super cool
Oh
chanceux d'être en vie en ce moment, alors
je viens de voir que nous avons survécu mais
c'était fou,
nous sommes irréels sur quelques morceaux de glace
J'ai un nœud à la main Je me suis cogné les côtes
avec un  morceau de glace, je suis complètement
trempé Josh le trempé, puis je l'ai gagné
après l'éclatement, nous avons pu
revoir l'iceberg et il est
tombé, vous savez, en tombant et cela a créé une
bonne vague de 8 10 12 pieds qui se dirigeait
tout droit  pour nous
, nous avons donc tous les deux fait demi-tour et
pagayé aussi vite que possible, essayant
de surfer sur la vague et heureusement,
tout s'est bien passé, donc
aucun regret
chanceux d'être en vie en ce moment, d'accord